so in the last two videos we were
talking about this constrained
optimization problem where we want to
maximize a certain function on a certain
set the set of all points X Y where x
squared plus y squared equals 1 and we
ended up working out through some nice
geometrical reasoning that we need to
solve this system of equations so
there's nothing left to do but to just
solve the system of equations I will
start with this first one at the top see
what we can simplify we notice there's
an X term in each one so we'll go ahead
and cancel those out which is basically
a way of saying we're assuming that X is
not 0 and we can kind of return to that
to see if x equals 0 could be a solution
so maybe we'll kind of write that down
we're assuming X is not equal to 0 in
order to cancel out and we kind of can
revisit whether that could give us
another possible solution later but that
will be 2 times y is equal to lambda
times 2 and then from here the the twos
can cancel out no worries about 2
equaling 0 and we know that y equals
lambda so that's a nice simplified form
for this equation and for this next
equation we can use what we just found
that Y is equal to lambda to replace the
lambda that we see and instead if I can
if I replace this with a y what I'm
going to get is that x squared is equal
to Y times 2 times y so that's 2 times y
squared and I'll leave it in that form
because I see that in the next equation
I see an x squared I say Y squared so it
might be nice to be able to plug this
guy right into it so in that next
equation x squared I'm going to go ahead
and replace that with y squared so
that's 2 y squared plus y squared equals
1 and then from there simplifies to 3
times y squared equals 1 which in turn
means Y squared is equal to 1/3 and so Y
is equal to plus or minus the square
root of 1/3 great so the
gives us why and I'll go ahead and put a
box around that that we have found what
why must be now if y squared is equal to
one-third then when we look up here and
we say sum two times y squared that's
going to be the same thing as two times
one third so two times one-third so if x
squared is equal to two-thirds what that
implies is that X is equal to plus or
minus the square root of two-thirds and
then there we go that's another one of
the solutions and I could write down
what lambda is right and we could I mean
in this case it's easy because y equals
lambda but all we really want in their
final form are x and y since that's
going to give us the answer to the
original constraint problem so this this
gives us what we want and we just have
that that pesky little possibility that
x equals zero to address and for that we
can take a look and say if x equals zero
you know let's go through the
possibility that maybe that's one of the
one of the constrained solutions well in
this equation that would make sense
since two times zero would equal zero in
this equation that would mean that we're
setting zero equal to lambda times two
times y well since lambda equals y that
would mean that for this side to equal
zero Y would have to equal zero so so
evidently you know if it was the case
that x equals zero that would have to
imply from the second equation that y
equals zero but if x and y both equals
zero this constraint can't be satisfied
so none of this is possible so we never
even had to worry about this to start
with but it's something you do need to
check just every time you're dividing by
a variable you're basically assuming
that it's not equal to zero so this
right here gives us four possible
solutions four possible values for x and
y that satisfy this constraint and which
potentially maximize this and remember
when I say potentially maximize the
whole idea of this Lagrange multiplier
is that we were looking for where
there's a point of tangency between the
contour lines so just to make it
explicit the four points that we're
dealing with here I'll write them all
here so X could be the square root of
two-thirds square root of two-thirds and
Y could be the positive square root of
one-third
and then we can basically just toggle
you know maybe X is the negative square
root of 2/3 and Y is still the positive
square root of one third or maybe X is
the positive square root of 2/3 and Y is
the negative square root of one third
kind of monotonous but just getting all
of the different possibilities on the
table here X is negative square root of
2/3 and then Y is positive no negative
that's the last one
square root of one-third so these are
the four points where the contour lines
are tangent and to find which one of
these maximizes our function here let's
go ahead and write down our function
again it gets easy to forget so the
whole thing we're doing is maximizing f
of X y equals x squared times y so let
me just put that down again we're
looking at f of X y is equal to x
squared times y so we could just plug
these values in and see which one of
them is actually greatest and the first
thing to observe is x squared is always
going to be positive so if I plug in a
negative value for Y right if I plug in
either this guy here or this guy here
where the value for y is negative the
entire function would be negative so I'm
just going to say that neither of these
can be the maximum because it'll be some
positive number some x squared times a
negative whereas I know that these guys
are going to produce a positive number
and specifically you know if we plug in
if we plug in F of let's say this top
one square root of 2/3 square root of
1/3 well x squared is going to be 2/3
and then Y is square root of 1/3 and in
fact that's going to be the same as what
we get plugging in this other value so
either one of these maximizes the
function it's got two different
maximizing points and each one of them
has a maximum value of 2/3 times the
square root of 1/3 and that's the final
answer but I do want to emphasize that
the takeaway here is not the specific
algebra that you work out going towards
the end but it's the whole the whole
idea of this Lagrange multiplier
technique to find the gradient of one
function find the gradient of the
constraint function and then set them
for
to each other that's the that's the key
takeaway and then the rest of it is just
you know making sure that we check our
work and go through the minor details
which is important it has its place and
coming up I'll go through a few more
examples